See your pattern is scored based on the number 10. So out of 10 is your mark. As you can see
it's split up into two parts. We have our accuracy and our presentation on this side. So we'll start
off with the accuracy first. So your accuracy it's actually scored from a 4. So from the number 4
you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one any
mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus of a 0.1. If it's a major
mistake you get minus 0.3. So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake it's a very very small thing. So say we're doing a powder block. If it's
not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a
minor mistake so that's a 0.1. A major mistake is a minor mistake. So if it's a minor mistake
would be you're supposed to do an out of block in the pattern but you forget and you say you do a
rich hand strike instead. So that would be a major mistake. So with a minor mistake let's say pattern
one for example there's about 20 steps. It's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14-15 mistakes in the
20 patterns sorry the 20 steps. So the reason for that would be it needs to be absolutely perfect to
get a
to not get a deduction of 0.1. So it's not uncommon to say there's 20 steps and you made
let's say 15 mistakes. So what would that be? So we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come
back and we'll just calculate the score at the end. So a major mistake say you're supposed to
turn to the left but you turn to the right that would be a major mistake. So obviously we do want
to try to avoid any of these major mistakes.
After we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the presentation side. So the presentation as
you can see it's from a score of 6. This 6 is actually split up into three parts. So we have
1, 2, 3 here. So with this one for a score of 2 is your power and speed. Your rhythm is also a score
of 2 and your expression of energy is also scored out of 2 as well. So we'll start off with the power
and speed. So with this one whether it's your block,
your kicks, your strikes, your punches, anything that you do, you need to be nice and strong and
it has to be fast as well. So it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but
it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category. The next part is your rhythm. So
the rhythm, when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern. It's not just really
fast all the way through, it's not slow all the way through. There's a slow,
fast,
slow fast kind of aspect to it as well so you do need to kind of work on your
rhythm and that's also scored out of the two the last bit is your expression of
energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically how loud you shout
so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so say you're doing
your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is
really great but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the
judges can kind of tell oh you're not really confident or you're a little bit
nervous so that's why I went into kind of your proven point as well this time
so with this one for color belts and black belts it's actually scored a
little bit differently so if your color belt you'll actually your average so
where where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is
your average so say you did
So if you did alright, you did average compared to everyone else, your score for 1, 2 and 3, it'll start from a 1.1. So if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your power and speed, you might get a 1 or even a 0.9. If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4.
So each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can. If you're a black belt, generally depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3. So 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So say your power and speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now. Say your rhythm was only about average.
But it wasn't amazing. It might be just a 1.3. But let's say you didn't shout very loud. So your expression of energy, your average was 1.3. It might drop to, say, let's say a 1.0.
So with this one, we'll come over down to this slide. So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10. So let's see. So for presentation, we have 0.7.
1, 2, 3. So you added 3.7. Let's say you made 15 mistakes. So with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is with the judges. We have three judges usually at the panel. And each judge, obviously, is very subjective. So from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So we have two judges. We have three judges. And we average without installing. Okay. So say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes. So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5. So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5. So this would be your accuracy score.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.0. So let's say we did 3.0. And we have 3.1. So this would be our accuracy score. So with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.0.
So with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.0. So let's say we got a 3.0.
point seven here so we add these numbers at the after the judges are finished
scoring so you would get for this pattern a six point three which is
actually very good so I'll just talk about a little bit more now about this
number here so if you're a color belt if you're a yellow or above and you do your
patterns it's not uncommon generally for a color belt the average is about a
four to five so if you get a number between four and five out of ten for
your pattern that's actually generally considered pretty good so anything above
that uh you can consider yourself pretty good if you're a black belt the average
would say because um we're talking here about the the high presentation as an
average anything from five to two sorry five to six is actually considerably
controlled instead of few uh it just becomes very controlled as more like um
considered pretty good and anything over a 7 is considered almost world class so if you
get a 7 for any of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an
amazing job so we just went through our pointe scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0
presentation is a 6.0 accuracy is during your pattern presentation is after and then we
get two scores that we add up so we get that number so with this one obviously say I was
I was judge number one I would give you a 6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe
he saw a couple more mistakes than I did so maybe this one would be a little bit lower
it might be a 5 point something another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher
so we get the three numbers and then we average that as well so you hope this
helped you guys and I hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see you in the next one bye bye
I hope you guys so I'll make sure you enjoy your pointe competition and any time I make sure
obviously you record down your numbers as well so
real time real time we cannot pause this time like a real
judge and then major errors and then after the performance
and rate power and speed and coordination rhythm and expression of energy okay yeah
no pausing
the song
yeah
okay
good
thank
you
great
should
you
guys
so
great
day
okay
see you
thanks
we love it
so
that was
yeah
thank you
and I'd love to have more time for the discussion
be with
you
like
share
all
it
so
bye
show
so
Thank you.